Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie, Happy Halloween!
This is going to be my Doctor Who Episode
7 video.
This is another two-parter just like the Maisie
Williams Episodes.
Just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet.
There was a whole bunch of classic Zygon stuff.
Unlike the Daleks, there haven't been a ton
of Zygon episodes so there's not a whole lot
of stuff to refer to, so anytime the Zygons
are around there's a lot of unit stuff and
they refer back to terror the Zygons, the
classic who episode but new round of the giveaway
starts now to all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video.
It's a $20 Amazon card.
starting with number five explaining what
the hell is going on with the big prelude
it's almost like Doctor who is turning into
a clip show but it but essentially the prelude
to this was a clip show for the 50th anniversary
to explain how all the Zygons got planted
on earth and then for series 8 to explain
what happened to the real Osgood and why Zygon
Osgood is doing this so if for some reason
you didn't see the 50th anniversary in the
wake of that 20 million Zygon's basically
when into witness protection so to speak on
earth the two Osgood's message here basically
explained that there are good Zygon the just
want to live their life out of peace they
they don't want to cause anybody any trouble
and then in this episode we meet the bad Zygon
faction the radical faction that wants them
to be able to live as they normally looked
they they don't want to have to blend in so
that's the big point of contention you have
a bunch of different Zygon factions most of
them are relatively peaceful these two twin
girls were like the old high command on earth
the radicals icons like screw that we want
our home want to be able to walk around looking
like were supposed to look so there's any
confusion real Osgood the real Osgood died
during series 8 she really is dead this is
Zygon Osgood in the big WTF twisted the kind
of ties in with the ending is Zygon's don't
need to keep the people that they're doubling
as alive as it used to be that they had to
keep their double live so that means all these
people and pods including chloride they can
kill them off as soon as they're done getting
the information they need from them on the
number four divide and conquer so the episode
gets a little sprawling early on and everybody
splits off in different directions Kate Stewart
goes to truth or consequences turns out chloride
plays a lot of Trivial Pursuit the doctor
and Rebecca front go to the rebels Zygon base
and then there's cars group which goes underneath
her flat eventually one of the most interesting
things I noticed was when Kate went to the
Mexican town we heard that police officer
the we met speak and I couldn't remember the
last time I heard an American accent on Doctor
who except maybe during series 6 like a Ben
Browder kind of had an American accent Matt
Smith spoke with the fake American accent
so that's about as close as I think the show
is gone in recent memory that you guys can
remember the last time an American actor was
on Doctor who speaking with an American accent
let me know I have watched the entire run
of the think of it that it was fun seeing
Rebecca front Capaldi together again if Doctor
who were in such a family show I'm sure what
are her way more F bombs on the number three
Kate Stewart knows about some secret Zygon
weaponry that the doctor had stolen from them
so she references terror of the Zygon that
the 70s 80s Zygon invasion she was talking
about is a bio weapon that can take on a bunch
of Zygon's but the doctor took it to keep
them from using it to keep the humans from
turning into the villains and on this episode
were building towards his like to extremes
rehab extreme Zygon rebels that want to get
rid of the human race then you have Rebecca
front script that wants to new golf is Zygon's
the problem is and it's definitely highlighted
by car at the end of the episode is that nobody
knows who's the Zygon and who's a person so
the doctor can't let Rebecca front nuke everyone
can she might be killing a metahuman's to
any and he hates the idea of killing and just
in general on the number to the huge Easter
egg moment this is a section really fun Osgood
and the doctor talk all about?'s so this is
like a seventh Doctor think the seventh doctor
wore a?
Jumper and had a question mark umbrella so
when Osgood was wearing that?
That's what they were talking about but the
fourth the fifth and the sixth Doctor all
had question marks on their collars you can
also look at it more as a reference to them
with that?
Center callers as well as the seventh doctor
with question marks all over him but them
with the doctor says I'm wearing?
Underpants and she says that begs me to ask
what is the question so becomes of funny sexual
innuendo but it's also Matt Smith think the
final question that that was all tied up in
bringing the time Lords back during Matt Smith's
final episode during that the Christmas special
I love you even Zygon Osgood is a doctor fan
girl but finally on my number one WTF moment
the Zygon have replaced all the humans in
the UK the first battle is one now the war
begins meet meeting they're going to take
the rest of the world seeing evil Carl was
kind of fun in the session this shot of her
with a rocket launcher that was in the first
trail that they posted back during comic con
obviously this is a two-parter we know the
doctors can escape he always escapes but the
more interesting twist I think is what's going
on with Kate Stewart because Zygon Clar radios
her thinking she's calling that other Zygon
they are asking if the unit has been neutralized
Kate Stewart pretending to be's I got I think
says yes units been neutralized wrong.
The twist I think is the Kate Stewart had
awaited take down that Zygon so this is the
real Kate Stewart just pretending to be a
Zygon is one of those characters who just
a little bit more clever than everyone else
and not afraid to get her hands dirty if you
member back to the 50th anniversary she was
ready to nuke everything in the black archives
system pry has a couple cool tricks up her
sleeve let me know in the comments what you
think about the evil chloride twist at the
end I feel like this is a good Halloween episode
just because Zygon is a look a little bit
scarier and that the horror is is that everyone
has already been replaced the battle has already
been lost so definite bonus points awarded
for dropping this episode on Halloween I don't
of the planet that when advanced it is any
other Easter eggs you spot in the episode
that I didn't mention like you?
Steer the Zygon's for Doctor Stumpf just write
them below in the comments and congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner James Logan
you and a $20 Amazon gift card just be sure
to private message me on the back and my channels
and get your contact info was can happen next
is I haven't arrow Constantine trailer video
that I'm going to post later tonight hopefully
guys have an awesome Halloween I'm fully moved
into my new apartment I still have a bunch
of junk that I need to rearrange and stuff
but I will do a room tour video as soon as
I get all the furniture arranged and everything's
all organized so while you guys wait for that
stuff to post you can click here for last
weeks Maisie Williams episode and you can
click here for the flash trailer video that
I just posted explaining zoom and Doctor light.
Thanks so much for Watching, everybody High
Five and I'll see you tonight!